we have the system of equations y is
equal to 4x minus 17.5 and y plus 2x is
equal to 6 point 5 and we have to solve
for x and y so we're looking for X's and
Y's that satisfy both of these equations
now the easiest way to think about it is
we've already solved for y in this top
equation let me write it again I'll
write it in pink we have y is equal to
4x minus 17.5 so this first equation is
telling us literally by this constraint
Y should be 4 times X minus 17 and 1/2
now the second equation says whatever Y
is we add 2 times X and that should be 6
point 5 well the y here also has to meet
this constraint up here it also has to
meet the constraint that it has to be 4
times X minus 17.5 so what we can do is
is we can substitute this value for Y
into this equation let me be clear what
I'm doing the second equation here is y
plus 2x is equal to 6 point 5 we know we
know that Y has to be equal to this
thing right here Y has to be equal to 4x
minus 17.5 so let's take 4x minus 17.5
and substitute Y with that so let's put
that right there so if we were to do
that if we were to replace this Y with
4x minus 17.5 because that's what the
first equation is telling us then we get
4x minus 17.5 plus plus 2x is equal to
6.5 and now we have a single linear
equation with one unknown let's solve
for X so first we have our X terms we
have a 4x and we have a 2x we can group
them or add them together 4x plus 2x is
6x and then we have 6x minus 17.5
- 17.5 is equal to is equal to 6.5 then
we can get the 17.5 out of the way by
adding it to both sides of the equation
so this is negative 17.5 so let's add
positive 17.5 to both sides
of this equation and we are left with
the left-hand side is just going to be
6x because these guys cancel out 6x is
going to be equal to and 6.5 z6 plus 17
is 23 and then 0.5 plus 0.5 is 1 so this
is going to be 24 and then we can divide
both sides of this equation by 6 both
sides by 6 and you are left with X is
equal to X is equal to 24 over 6 which
is the same thing as 4 so we figured out
the x value that for the X&Y pair that
satisfy both of these equations now we
need to figure out the Y value and we
can do that by taking this X and putting
it back into one of these equations we
can do it into either one we should get
the same y value so let's just do this
top one up here so if we assume X is
equal to 4 this top equation tells us
that Y is equal to 4 4 times X which in
this case is 4 minus 17.5 - 17.5 well
this is equal to 16 minus seventeen
point five which is equal to negative
one point five so Y is equal to negative
point one point five so the solution to
this system is X is equal to 4 y is
equal to negative one point five and you
can even verify that these two they
definitely work for the top one if you
put 4 times 4 minus 17.5 you get
negative one point five but they also
work for the second one and let's do
that in the second one if you take
negative 1.5 plus 2 times X plus 2 times
2 times 4 what is that equal that's
negative 1.5 plus 8 well negative 1
point 5 plus 8 is 6 point 5 so this x
and y satisfy both of these equations